hey everybody yeah oh [ __ ] it's monday
what happened i'm way over there okay
now you're way over there way over there
plenty of room i'm in the video next to
this one
i still think that's super if i like
knew how to do that or had the time had
the time to like learn how to edit
videos yeah i could put two videos and
like would have tom like in one video
the other one that would be super funny
stuff is very funny but hey everybody
it's monday and you know what that means
uh it's time for us to talk about an
episode of haunting yeah everybody pours
in here fast when we do these haunting
episodes look at that
yeah this is
this was a good idea like
now like i said yesterday we had four
episodes that were recommended
so i wrote all those down and i said we
are gonna do those we'll do all like
over the next couple weeks but we just
didn't know what uh order we were gonna
do them in so last night we were just
kind of like we pulled them all out
because we had these on they're all good
and yeah they're all good but tom's like
oh let's do this one yeah actually this
was a good one to do because this is
actually the first episode technically
yeah the first real episode because i
was sitting there saying well didn't
they have like pilot episodes
haunting of georgia and haunting of
connecticut i think were longer they
were like an hour and a half
yeah they don't count those as part but
this was actually season one episode one
the fun funny thing is is i was looking
at i was looking at that dvd collection
and haunting of georgia isn't on it
well like i said they consider that a
separate yeah haunting of georgia and
haunting of connecticut are like special
yeah episodes and they were like pilot
yeah summer ones in there and they were
almost kind of like movies because i
think they were an hour and a half
i think they were like movie length yeah
i guess they didn't have uh they showed
those
or they should yeah they showed those
first and then like just to gauge i
guess what the interest was yeah and
then when they were successful they
started like going into production on
the season the good thing about this one
though which is called hell house by the
way
it's
it's season one episode one
but then if you look it up on wikipedia
like because there's a wikipedia page
called list of haunting episodes
and the production number on this is 103
which usually means season one episode
three but they might not they might have
counted the two pilots in there maybe
yeah maybe that's what it is yeah either
that or they shot this one
third and then showed it first i don't
know it's like it doesn't really matter
it does one and two is georgia and you
know one with mr gordy yeah and and
haunting again yeah but evidently this
company doesn't have didn't have the
rights to put them on the dvd collection
that's probably or what they probably
did is they probably released those
separately yeah
like i said because like i said those
are like movie length as far as i
remember because i have seen them but i
remember them being they might be on a
separate dvd that i don't have that's
yeah i think they were because they
technically weren't part of season one
right they were just like they were
pilots yeah
so and they aired like a lot earlier
yeah than this
but yeah so this is hell house and it's
season one episode one and this aired
for the first time
on october 28th just a couple days
before halloween of
2005. this is the ed and lorraine warren
case i had forgotten that the war i mean
the warrens are involved in a lot of the
[ __ ] and lorraine was still alive
when they did the show so they did
interview with us i think i think ed was
already dead by this point because he
got a lot
younger than it ever i've said before
we've said many times that the warrens
you know they were quite a piece of work
but they were prototypes in
in in the paranormal business okay and
they did make it a business all right
um
i wouldn't trust much of what they say
but they were on some real cases they
were you know sometimes they forced
their way into into interesting cases
like they weren't invited
like they weren't invited to to enfield
and the infield was a well-documented
case cops and
news people saw there's there's some
good british uh documentaries on the
infield case they just showed up
for like one day one day now they claim
to have solved it or yeah i think he
said oh there's nothing there
you know here's the thing too because i
feel like they always kind of got and i
think they even mentioned it on this
episode too was that they
um
were instrumental in investigating the
amityville apps or something like that
and i think like they were there but
that's a little bit misleading because
one i don't think they even went to
the amityville house until after
um you know the family had already moved
out
and i'm not really sure how much
investigating they did in there right
now not to say that they were
total hacks uh it's just i don't agree
with a lot of [ __ ] that they said you
know for them it was always demons
there was never anything about their
psychology no rspk no concept of they
had a kind of a weird concept of what a
poltergeist was they thought a
poltergeist was a free
form a free-floating fully formed like
demonic entity that just attached itself
to people which that's not what a
poltergeist is it's rspk recurrent
spontaneous cyclokinesis well if you
believe in demons you're gonna make
everything and you're gonna make
everything a demon just all right
oh and i've seen poltergeist i was a
focus you know as a kid we wrote a book
about it uh so if you guys are new to
the show um
it's called [ __ ] mammoth mountain
poultry guys you'll like it it's a good
book and it's true i lived it and uh
made my family my uncle my cousin
and uh still happens to to this day
every now and then depending on
what my mental state is at the time if
i'm [ __ ] frustrated or pissed off
something's gonna fall fly or break and
it's gonna be something impossible
weird
uh but that's poultry guys and it's not
a demon it is [ __ ] scary it's kind of
demonic it like it has a personality of
its own but it's like a character in one
of your dreams
it's like that
something in your subconscious
um
and the reason why i mentioned in this
is because
in this episode
it's portrayed as a demon but i'm
watching the pattern on how things
unfold and the people that are involved
in it i believe if this case is real
which it does seem like sound like
something that really could happen
similar to some of the stuff that
happened to me
um
this is a poltergeist i think it's the
teenage girl doing it i mean very early
on it did seem very poltergeist yeah
they went in try to exercise and treat
it like a demon and poultry guys
phenomenal is just going to adapt to
whatever the crowd wants
you know so they're suggesting that it's
now a demon it becomes
exactly it's not even a ghost they
usually start off
pretending well this one has ghosts and
demons yeah ghost and demons together
well that's because it starts off the
kid thinks it's a ghost
so it acts like a ghost and then
somebody else shows up and says it's a
demon so now it becomes oh it's a ghost
and a demon
yeah because it can't back up can't back
off the first
character so it's a ghost and it's
just going to add [ __ ] on yeah
it's a ghost that has possession of
demons
or a demon that has possessions yeah
demon that has possession of ghosts yeah
i'm not i'm actually like really glad
like i don't remember who it was that um
because i know like a couple of you guys
like gave us recommendations when i
asked for uh your favorite episodes and
i know somebody recommended this one and
i had forgotten about this one but then
when we re-watched it and i'm like how
did i forget this one this one's
actually really good this is one of the
best ones this is a good episode and
like i said it's kind of like the first
one yeah
so
uh it's a good that what i'm gonna start
to do
because we got really lucky like the
first time we did a haunting episode
because there's a site that has like uh
transcripts of like various tv shows and
the first episode we did
um which was what i think it was dark
wrath and i think somebody like they
somebody had done like a transcript of
that episode and i was like whoo like i
didn't have to take it so i was like
well i don't have to take notes um but
then like the one we did last week
didn't have a transcript and i was like
well [ __ ] so then like we watched it
that evening and i was like well crap
now i have to watch it again so i had to
watch it again like to take notes and
everything yeah so when we watched this
one last night i said just in case i
took my notebook in the bedroom and i
just like and i wrote down notes like
the whole time of like
of like what was happening so i was like
i don't want that to happen again i
don't want to have to watch the whole
episode over again
so i think i got like a pretty good
handle of like all the stuff that was
like now i made some comments during
that did you write down any of the
comments i didn't know if you
were you know it didn't it brought
enough it would help well you will
probably remember like when i talk about
like what happened yeah
because certain things happened in a
certain order and i'm like that's
usually the order it happens in in
what's called poltergeist phenomena
and that's how i mean i just wrote
everything down just like it happened
yeah even down to rapping
that's a poltergeist thing
rapping and knocking yeah like answering
questions knocking not like yeah not
like rapping yeah not rapping like
that
knocking knocking in places tupac is
haunting myself yeah yeah
and you can communicate and it would
answer and knock so that's that's that's
[ __ ] classic poltergeist easy to do
that through rspk
yeah they didn't treat it like that
though but you know that doesn't usually
happen and i will say too that
i usually try and find like some outside
sources like if there's other because
like i said when we did dark wrath like
that lady that was on there had actually
written a book about her experiences um
that doesn't again that doesn't usually
happen this one it didn't happen there
wasn't a huge amount of outside
information about this one but i did
find a like uh one article about it so
we'll talk about that after
so okay
so this concerns
the beckwith family
they buy this old like if the house had
been repossessed right like it was an
old repossessed house and it was in a
town called seymour which is in rural
connecticut they actually did use the
real uh name of the town this time
because i looked it up and that's where
the house is
so they bought the house in 1998 now
because the house had been repoed
uh the price was of course too good to
be true did you guys not see the
amityville horror that never ends well
but you know whatever
um and apparently it was like a pretty
big house i think it like needed some
work obviously i think a lot of these do
but um you know but it was pretty big
so the family we got here like i said
it's the beckwith family the dad is sean
the mom is bonnie
and they have three kids now sean was
like a heating and ac guy i think and
bonnie was a nurse now the weird thing
about this one okay so there were three
kids right
that's what they showed in the car and
blah blah but only two of them were
named on the show i guess the other one
was like [ __ ] it i don't want my name
being known on the show maybe
uh and only one of the kids like one of
like the middle daughter she appeared on
the show like you know grown up yeah and
she said i believe was the focus
yeah so i was kind of so for a little
while i was kind of confused about which
because the weird thing about like the
actress that they got to play the actual
girl that was being interviewed on the
show looked more like the actress that
they had playing the other daughter you
know what i mean so it's just like the
other daughter that they had who wasn't
really named yeah
looked kind of like the real so i kept
thinking that was her i'm just like what
the [ __ ] is going on so it's like yeah i
was like really confused no the one that
was the one that was portraying the
actual daughter was the one that was
getting punched in the back when she was
in yeah and she was like a blonde but
but the girl in real life was a brunette
and then the actress that they had
playing the older daughter who they
never name in the show is a brunette so
i kept thinking
that that was that girl but it's not
i don't know when somebody changed their
hair color
maybe before they [ __ ] recorded the
show i don't know maybe i don't know
what it was she might have been blonde
at the time maybe or maybe they didn't
care they just maybe yeah they were just
like whatever they're just like whoever
because like i said a haunting i feel
like they use like the same the same
stable of actors because i think the dad
who doesn't really factor a lot into
this one i don't even think he has that
many lines
um because he doesn't get interviewed on
the show i think it's basically mostly
just the mom
and the middle daughter like they were
the only actual family members that
showed up like the sun didn't show up
the dad didn't show up nobody did no the
dad was the actual dad it wasn't it
wasn't a step dad
yeah as far as i know okay yeah yeah
yeah all right i mean they didn't say
anything about videos yeah the actual
the actual uh girl
that was seemed to be what was called
the focus
um
she's probably about 18 or 19 when she's
doing an interview and she just kind of
struck me as like yeah that's that's the
kind of girl that would be a poultry
guy's focus you know what i mean she
just kind of looked like it just kind of
got that feeling from her
she was cute um
and
a lot of it has to do
if you look through
the real cases now you can fake a case
because
pros
know what a real case sounds like and
they can just tell a story that
fits that mold
so if this case actually happened and
sometimes a paranormal witness takes
liberties with what the witnesses said
to try to make a better show well no uh
haunting the haunting yeah yeah
i get the show's mixing i mean
paranormal witnesses
a haunting will kind of take liberties
with what so when i say if this case
really happened what i mean is if this
case happened as portrayed by a haunting
i'm going to say it's poltergeist it
fits that
okay
and i think she was the focus if if if
the story's being told correctly or the
way it really happened yeah i mean it's
hard to say because it's possible they
do
you know we talked about this before
they do exaggerate things like to make
the show better or scary or more
entertaining or whatever and i have seen
some families that were on there that
really did believe that like bad should
happen to them but they said yeah the
show exaggerated or changed the [ __ ]
around or whatever the the the typical
pattern is is young female
round 14 15.
um family tension possibly kind of like
poverty or family breakup happening at
the same time she had a premonition
about the house before she ever got no
that was the older older one that was
the one they didn't name that's what i
was going to
she had a premonition which that kind of
ran true to me because you guys if you
guys have read the book going up to
mammoth mountain i had a bad feeling
that i was going to a place that was
kind of like something out of shining
yeah like like you were going to there
yeah yeah and we were going up the
sierra nevada mountains and you'd never
been there no i've never been there and
then when i got there man it was just
overwhelming [ __ ] feelings of being
watched which that's mentioned also in
this and the place that's charged up for
poltergeist activity it feels like
you're being watched jenny's felt like
she's being watched when there's
phenomena happening in here but it's
nowhere near as strong as it was she
only got a real small taste of it
when i was
15 or 14 i remember how old i was at the
time i think 14.
it was about 30 times what you felt
that's what the intensity was like i
mean you could almost like cut it with a
knife the weird thing about that is that
the only time i mean other than like
when all the poltergeist [ __ ] was going
on here like with your thing
i you know i never really felt as much
like i was being watched as
one time in my life and it didn't really
have anything to do with anything i was
sitting at the dining room table at my
grandmother's house like years ago and i
was just sitting there like we're like
writing in my notebook or something like
that
and i felt like
i mean i was convinced that somebody was
standing right behind me looking at
looking at the back of your neck
and it was and i had never felt that in
that house i never thought that house
was haunted i lived there for years and
years and i never felt anything i don't
know why i felt that like all of a
sudden but i was just like what the [ __ ]
and i like went like that and of course
there was nobody there and then i i kind
of laughed because there was a cabinet
right behind there that had my
grandfather's ashes in it and i was like
is my grandfather like creeping up and
like behind me it's like that's the
first thing that i thought but that's
really the most strong that i've ever
felt that and i have never felt it that
strong before or since now sometimes
when i do commentary on these things on
on these shows i will describe something
almost in star wars terms like the force
and the dark side and i'd do that
because there is truth to it
lucas didn't invent any of that stuff
they got a lot of that from taoism and
buddhism okay and there's truth to i've
read a lot of that stuff and it's
yeah there's truth to what to say so
that feeling
that we're talking about being watched
i feel it's kind of like
an area has become psychically charged
and a person could charge that area up
before they even got there
because the person the
let's just say the psychic or the person
who's sensitive force sensitive maybe
that's what you want to call it star
wars terms
even though they physically have never
been to that location
part of them in the spirit world is
outside the space-time continuum so
part of that person's soul knows where
they're gonna be
so it's charging it up before the
the body ever gets there
because there's a part of your soul that
is slightly in a higher dimension
outside of space and time and knows
where you're going to be
that's probably where premonitions come
from and if you have out-of-body
experiences
which i've had those in a near-death
experience time is not quite the same
it's a singularity and once you're
outside of it you can see past present
and future all happening as a single
as a single event and you can insert
yourself any place in it
and it was kind of represented to me as
a [ __ ] wheel or a disc or a or a
record album where you could jump in
anywhere it's like if you could put the
neo needle anywhere it'd be a good way
to describe it a record album is
recorded
it's like a singularity you can put the
needle in any place
and time it be in any kind of song
well space time is kind of like that in
another dimension not this dimension
it's in another dimension and part of
your soul if that's what you want to
call it is in that other dimension
stuart hamroff calls it
the quantum soul theory which that
sounds
right to me
it's your mind is a
quantum particle's in superposition and
it's outside the brain and it's the soul
you know
and i don't think the brain is
generating it i think it's just looking
through your brain it's kind of
organizing what the soul does
breath of con 87 says awesome cannon
shirt where did you get that and then
danny rowling said uh he made it yeah
made that well we made that shirt i
designed it and he screen printed it yep
i did the same with this one i designed
this one and we screen printed this one
as well we screen print our own shirts
like one at a time yep oh it's all hand
hand screen printed and everything for a
20 super chat i'll send you one
yeah i mean like i'll need your con's in
mexico
no this is wrath of khan 87.
this is a different place
yeah we have another one that's called
oslo and that's who we thought i was
talking about yeah if you're in the
continental united states i can i can
guarantee you get it to you for 20. yeah
we got new ink coming uh and i think
it's supposed to be here tomorrow
so we'll see how that goes because we
ran out
uh but yeah okay so yeah i got confused
about the whole daughter situation yeah
but what it is when i finally figured it
out like after i did it like a little
bit more research so you got the parents
right now they have an eight or nine
year old kid like at one point he said
he was nine but then like later he said
he was eight so whatever he was eight or
nine and his name is jeremy that's the
son
and then the 15 year old girl at least
in 1998 when they uh moved there and her
name was jennifer and that was the one
that was growing up that was talking on
the show
and then there was another daughter who
was an older teenager i don't know how
old she was i'm assuming 16-7 she could
drive so i'm guessing she was like 16 or
17. um and i don't think they ever named
her and they didn't really have a lot of
[ __ ] of hers going on now the older
daughter who was unnamed
daughter x
she's the one that had like the
premonition about the house like they
the whole family goes to look at it
before they bought it
and they're kind of like okay well we
want to buy this one but we want the
whole family to see it how do you guys
feel about it and she goes there and
apparently at least this is what they
showed on the show she wasn't on the
show so i don't really know if this is
true or not but she said or you know
they showed on the show that the
basement door i guess like opened by
itself
and she was like weirded out and she was
like i don't like this place um i think
she said it's evil at least according to
her mom and she's like we shouldn't move
here this is like bad news
but nobody else felt anything so she
kind of got outvoted you know what i
mean like i said this is the older
daughter i don't know what her name is
she wasn't on the show they're just like
so it's all like secondhand information
so they move in now the first thing that
happens is jeremy the kid the little kid
he starts hearing
some weird like knocking or banging
noises
and some weird noises that kind of
sounded like i don't know like
skittering or
something like in his room now let me
say something in the poltergeist cycle
noises tend to start first because
that's the easiest thing to generate
whoever's generating these things or the
focus
they
they're building their confidence up the
subconscious is building the confidence
up trying to figure out what it is that
it could do the easiest phenomenons are
are audio audio
and then it starts trying to move things
then it starts to make things try to
appear
but okay good
uh so yeah so he hears all these noises
he complains to his mom he's like hey
i'm like hearing all this weird [ __ ] in
my room his mom tells him like she had
bought him this toy flashlight like one
of those ones i know what they're
talking about but one of those ones that
like has three colors it's like red
green blue or something like you could
switch to the colors you guys probably
know what i'm talking about there's toy
flashlights
so we had one of those and she tells him
this
[ __ ] story that it's like well all
you have to do is flash the green light
at whatever it is like the monsters
because she don't really believe him i
guess
um and it'll make him go away and he
buys it and i was like you know what i
kind of feel like maybe and maybe i
don't know maybe not in 1998 i don't
have any kids so i don't really know but
an eight or nine year old boy you'd
think be like that's [ __ ] mom you
know what i mean i don't know
so i'm just saying
uh but of course
you know that doesn't end up working uh
i i just kind of feel like an eight or
nine year old boy would probably be too
old to fall for that [ __ ] but i
don't know maybe it was different in
1998
so
she does that she tells him that and
then like he starts hearing the sounds
again later but it's like louder this
time and he's like peeking out of the
thing and he apparently sees
and like i said he wasn't on the show
talking so i don't know you know he's
just going we're just going by what the
mom said
that he said and what they're showing in
the show and he apparently saw this kind
of like big shadow figure that looked
like it was like kind of dart across the
wall
so he hides under the covers and then
something rips the covers off and like
throws them across the room
so remembering what his mom said he
shines the green light on the flashlight
like hey go away but of course that that
didn't do that didn't do dick because
like she was just trying to make him
feel better she didn't know
now according to the mom like for a long
time like after they moved in jeremy
would pretty much wake up screaming
every night saying he was hearing things
and seeing things in his room
and she just thought
you know you wouldn't really think
anything about it i guess if you're a
mom and he's just like still kind of a
little kid
but then
jennifer the 15 year old
she starts feeling weirded out in her
room too
uh at first mostly feeling like she's
being watched all the time this is
around the same time or i guess like i
said it's a haunting so it's like
sometimes like sometimes they'll be like
two days later or something like that
but then sometimes they'll just kind of
be like about the time a while later or
you know what's whatever
usually if you actually read the real
credible and documented cases it's the
poltergeist focus or the person that's
making it happen is the first one to
witness it
that's usually how it goes wouldn't
surprise me as if she witnessed it first
maybe and didn't say anything or didn't
know that she wouldn't because the first
thing that they put on the show was that
the little kid started hearing things
when i first started seeing it i wasn't
sure if something just fell over because
it fell over or if it was pushed over
you know what i mean it was hard to tell
like remember when the
when they uh my little
travel bag
yeah i left it on the bed turned my back
on it came back with a suitcase and saw
the travel bag on its side and some
socks rolled up socks go
fly they were flying they were in motion
when i saw them and they just kind of
screeched to a halt when i looked at it
and i said
it looked weird
it almost the socks almost looked like
they were blurring when they [ __ ]
stopped
and i was like yeah it's like it
couldn't move it when you were looking
at it it was just a weird thing it's
like looking at it caused him to stop
moving
and i wasn't sure
if it just fell over and i kind of
imagined that or or what so i just blew
it off i didn't i didn't realize that
that was that was the first thing i saw
and i didn't realize it until later once
it had been confirmed that more [ __ ] was
moving
so it might have been that i was getting
it out already by the time that that
even happened if you see something
that's kind of like still hasn't
plausible deniability yeah
and that was the first thing that hammed
and it was with and now it had only been
in that house for five minutes it wasn't
ramp it was instant not even five
minutes maybe two minutes
well yeah wow this place is [ __ ]
weird i'm going to take this room and
went into that room just put the bag
there went back out the car which was
only
right in front of the door parking lot
was right there and it went back in and
saw that something hit like something
had knocked over the bag was rummaging
through it and [ __ ] socks stopped
moving
that's weird it is pretty weird and i
was like what
and i thought it maybe just fell over
and it the socks rolled out well yeah
that's what you would think yeah that's
what i thought
but
how did it open
because it had a zipper on top of it
because it kind of had two straps this
little 70s looking thing
yeah i remember those yeah
so yeah so at this point so jennifer is
like weirding out her room like feeling
like everybody's watching her right
so then one night like jared they can't
kind of do a jump scare like on the show
where jeremy comes into her room and
tells her hey i'm getting freaked out
like somebody keeps calling my name he
apparently said and ripping the covers
off him which yeah that would be like
pretty good scare the [ __ ] out of me if
you were eight or nine years old well
that would scare the [ __ ] out of me like
right now well i don't know would it
yeah it probably would hell yeah
but then i'd just be like i don't know i
think it would be kind of like
interesting also yeah
i'd be kind of like interested
so this apparently the same night that
that happened that the little kid came
into her room and said you know all kind
of weird shits happen in my room
jennifer's bed starts shaking now she is
on the show so she described it she said
it felt like
someone was like under the bed punching
the underside of the mattress with their
fist
and it was like causing the whole bed to
move that's what she said it felt like
yeah
so of course she jumps out the bed like
what the [ __ ] and it like looks under
there and of course there's nobody there
i could imagine that
but luckily luckily my poultry has never
touched me it touched lois but it didn't
touch me
weird well didn't you ask it not to yeah
i said don't you ask
i [ __ ] said don't you [ __ ] touch
me
i don't want to see you
so it never even appeared i was afraid
it would appear as like some rotten
corpse or something [ __ ] scared
and it never it only looking like the
crips keeper yeah some [ __ ] it only
appeared as like a bluish haze
like a bluish haze or a [ __ ] kind of
a weird translucent ball that you
about the size of a softball or a
cantaloupe and you're not really sure if
it was there if you if you looked
directly at it it vanished but if you
looked a little bit beside it you could
kind of see an image and me and red are
like you see that like yeah
you try to focus on it it wasn't there
it wasn't there but if you look to the
side you can kind of see it like a
distortion it's weird it's up there in
the corner of the [ __ ] room up there
in the corner near the ceiling
and then we'd be like it's gone like
yeah it is it's gone we could we would
both agree when it was when it was there
or when it wasn't there
like some kind of and it had a kind of a
presence to it felt like that there was
somebody watching you from there like
that's where the that's where the like
where it was consciousness was yeah it
was up in a corner looking at you
something like that but yeah so
so yeah so she feels this on in her bed
right so she jumps out like obviously
and looks under the bed obviously
there's nobody there now she's like well
i didn't really want to tell my parents
because i thought that they wouldn't
believe me she's like so really the only
thing that i could think of to do
was to move the bed across the room yeah
you know oh no when she said that i've
it got more credibility with me because
we were trying to do irrational things
like that
too and doing it right you know like
well yeah like what else could you do i
mean it's just kind of like
well i'll move it over here maybe the
ghost doesn't like this corner you know
what i mean or whatever well
you're just trying to
you're trying to find a solution some
way
yeah you know what i mean yeah so that
made total sense like when she said that
even though you know it's not going to
do anything like that made total sense
that you maybe it did kind of do
something
i don't know maybe it didn't she didn't
say that it did it anyway
no yeah it did because absolutely
yeah well see that's what happens when
you jump ahead because
okay that's right so she moves the bed
across the room because that's all she
can think of to do two nights later
though yeah
she's laying on her bed in the evening
and she's like talking on the phone
and the bed starts moving by itself
again it was kind of like what they
showed on the show was kind of like
shaking like exorcist style where i
don't know if it was like all like
coming off the floor and stuff but it
was like somebody was like somebody
really strong was like underneath it
like punching yeah and it was kind of
like rattling it kind of thing that's
she said that's what's weird is that i
guess because not everybody has agreed
that this is a phenomenal that's
actually happening that they're still
separate as soon as we all realized that
this was something that was happening in
in my case
we were all in the same room together
pretty much always
if anybody went to the bathroom somebody
was
outside the door and guarding you
yeah it's like being in her house with a
monster
gardenia like pookie stays up and guards
us every night
well you you're not sure what could
happen
i mean it was definitely strong enough
to kill you didn't seem to be you just
you know what i mean you're very uh
nobody wants to be by themselves
yeah i get it well that happens in this
one too but yeah it takes a while i mean
the first night they were [ __ ] we did
try to sleep separate but i was sleeping
upstairs on the couch and wesley was
still downstairs it didn't really seem
to bother him
but it [ __ ] did bad [ __ ] on that day
and after that we were all up on the
[ __ ] high to bed
sleeping in the living room on the high
to bed yeah
so at this point i guess like the
morning after that happened uh you know
they do kind of like a fake jump scare
among the hedges that's what i wrote my
uh notes because they did a thing like
you know for the show they're trying to
make it more like a horror movie so
jennifer is like trying to find her mom
and she's like where's my mom and she's
like out in the yard and it's like it
looks like a hedge maze from the [ __ ]
shiny or whatever and then like she sees
the hedge moving and she's like what the
[ __ ] is that and just like oh it's mom
so you know so it was a mom jump scare
so she finds mom
and she tells her about what happened
now bonnie i don't know if she didn't
like initially believe she was skeptical
though but she was concerned enough that
she's like okay we're gonna have like a
family meeting about this stuff and see
what we can
see
so they get everybody together and it
turns out that all of the kids have been
having similar experiences in their room
because i'm assuming that jeremy the
little kid the little boy like didn't
tell the mom about the [ __ ] either and i
guess jeremy didn't either and i don't
know about the older sister like i said
she didn't want to move to the house we
don't really know that much about her
input i don't even know what her name
was but um yeah so
apparently they're all having similar
kind of like situations happening
hearing weird noises like beds moving
stuff like that
so
the mom and the dad
like i said the dad doesn't really
factor into this one all that much uh
they don't really like ask him about it
he's not interviewed on the show
the actor doesn't really have that many
lines or whatever
so evidently they were just kind of like
okay kids we believe you and you know
what that means that means it's time to
call the warrens time to call the
warrens
i mean they called the warrens like
pretty early they were famous then
well yeah i guess yeah i wonder how they
found their got their number
whenever they found their number
let's see it was 1998.
so it wasn't that it wasn't yes i mean
they had internet back then yeah but i
mean
yeah i guess yeah so they probably went
to their terrible lakes just went off
the website angelfire website or
whatever it was back in 1998. was that
still a [ __ ] yeah i probably remember
i was there but i don't remember
she was coming and going real fast
prodigy yeah
and like all the websites although all
the websites were terrible and ugly and
it's just like it was just like you
could make your own just by asking
answering questions and pressing yes and
no just like all these like ugly links
everywhere like flashing gifs and all
this other kind of [ __ ] but yeah i
[ __ ] miss old internet though it was
like the wild west i don't you're just
slow that was a problem
if you actually if you want to see old
internet i think you can go to uh who's
that cult that had the nikes and all
like yeah
like committed suicide yeah i know what
you're talking about i think their
website still looks like that
someone still maintained it though like
it's still around but i think heaven's
gate yeah heaven's gate there you know i
think it still looks like that i could
be wrong they could have like updated it
at this point because i kind of feel
like is that even sustainable like i was
just go to [ __ ]
squarespace or weebly or something and
make a [ __ ] good look you can't get
on myspace anymore i think it's gone
oh no i said squarespace no i know that
but i'm telling myspace and that was
that wasn't even as old as that so i'm
not sure you could even
get on that [ __ ] anymore you probably
could well like i said i don't know
where they're hosting the [ __ ] yeah you
know what i mean
so they call the war ends up now
lorraine uh was actually still alive
when this show was recorded so she's
interviewed on the on the [ __ ]
and she said of course this is what
she's gonna say as soon as she walked in
she knew the place was infested i think
that's the word she used as fasted
uh and of course the darkest energy
coming from jennifer's room
it's weird because once the warrens
showed up because it feels like the
little boy
they were focusing on him at the
beginning because he had most of the
[ __ ] happening like oh i saw like a big
shadow darting across and like all the
noise and stuff but then after the
warrens showed up they're like oh they
mostly concentrated on jennifer's room
they're like that's where all the bad
shit's happening so i don't know
so lorraine tells them well i kind of
want to wan i want some more like
physical evidence so why don't you guys
like start keeping cameras by your bed
so that if you feel like something's
watching you in the room or something
like take pictures around the room and
see like what comes out on the pictures
that's what she told them to do yeah
so bonnie's mom that's it now bonnie is
the mom and this is her mom's this is
grandma
she comes to visit for thanksgiving now
this is the first time she's been here
presumably
because they just moved there so she
stays in the guest room
now jennifer described her as like a
real
she said she was like real humorous
and that she would always make jokes
about you know even real bad [ __ ] that
was happening like to try and make
everyone laugh and feel better about it
you know what i mean like she was one of
those kind of women
um
so grandma is in the spare room trying
to watch tv
but the damn thing keeps going off by
itself and she's just like what the [ __ ]
and she just like keeps turning it back
on with like the remote control like why
does this [ __ ] keep going off so after a
few times though like when it goes off
then she notices the reflections of
three dudes like in the blank tv screen
like it goes off and she sees like three
guys like that and she like whips around
but nobody's back there yeah
and that's just probably wouldn't know
what the [ __ ] we're talking about back
in those days since crt televisions were
they were gray but they were had they
were glass like and then reflective when
they weren't on
and you could
you could see what was behind you like
in a mirror
you know what i mean you could see in
the damn thing when it was off
and nowadays in [ __ ] flat screen
televisions and second they don't do
that anymore
but back in those days you could see a
reflection in a tv screen wait i i feel
like you could maybe still see it well
it depends on what the lighting is like
i guess in the room not really not like
it was i'm well our room is like
constantly dark so crt screen was good
that's true okay so it was glass
so they're real reflective today it's
just kind of a matte plastic clear
plastic you can't really get a
reflection in it anymore
but yeah can you like yeah i feel like
that's kind of like a trope on a
haunting though it's like where you kind
of like you turn the tv off and you're
like holy [ __ ] there was like because
that happened on dark wrath too like she
saw seth in the thing but yeah so she
sees the three guys she whips around
there's nobody there and then she whips
back around i think like the editing was
weird in this situat in this kind of
like scene but she whips back around to
the front
and then she sees allegedly
again i guess like an apparition it just
it on the show it looked like just a
dead dude who was maybe like sitting in
the chair next to the tv i couldn't
really tell
um
this wasn't specifically mentioned by
any of the fam family members like the
grandma wasn't interviewed either so i'm
not sure if this was just added for
effect or
was just like an extension of the three
reflections that she saw like this is a
like they wanted to make it look more
impressive or something like that so i'm
not really sure because nobody said hey
she whipped back around and then there
was a dead guy sitting in the chair next
to it but that's kind of what it looked
like but the editing was weird so i
couldn't really tell
um but regardless uh it was bad enough
that grandma would just like nope the
[ __ ] out the next morning she was like
nope i said i'm not staying here bye and
she left i don't know if it was before
or after thanksgiving did she even like
get any turkey or no because i was like
she probably stayed for turkey i don't
like i was gonna say it's like i don't
know why that was so important to me to
know
because i'm like i don't know if even if
there was ghosts in my room like i think
i'm gonna
i'm gonna at least stay for some turkey
i'll i'll tough it out but for
thanksgiving dinner because that's my
favorite but yeah so she nopes out
so after she leaves jennifer said
remembers what lorraine said about the
cameras so she goes into the spare room
and starts just like taking pictures and
she said while she was taking pictures
in there she said the temperature
dropped like significantly and the mom
said
that the room was like 40 degrees colder
than the rest of the house they said the
rest of the house was like you know 73
75 degrees that room almost felt like
freezing temperature like in the 30s
that's what she said yeah it was weird
it was like that mountain too
but it was it was snowing outside so it
was hard to tell
we'd set the [ __ ] thermostat and it
still it might say 70 in there but it
still felt freezing cold
but it didn't feel like a real cold it
just felt like something sucking heat
out of you
it felt it felt paranormal
didn't feel normal it's weird you
weren't sure if the chill was
down your back or if it was on your skin
you don't talk about
yeah just like that you weren't sure if
it didn't feel normal the temperature
but you weren't sure if it was
temperature
or if it was like psychology somehow
emotion it was hard to tell it's hard to
tell the difference
i don't know it's just weird nothing we
never really could put our finger on
yeah just felt cold in there at certain
times sometimes sometimes it would just
be
like in a little zone that you could
walk through it and then walk back
through it it feels cold right there but
you weren't sure
if it was natural or not you know and
just weird
danny rowling says
good job jenny i'm bringing all this
knowledge to the show about these cases
that weren't even in the episodes well i
kind of feel like that makes it more
interesting because i like the episodes
but i don't want to just i mean i want
to talk about what happened in the
episode but i kind of want like more
context on it if i can find any
so uh so yeah so the grandma leaves now
the warrens come back after thanksgiving
and they bring with them like two
researchers
that's what they called them on the show
one's just a regular ass paranormal
investigator with all those cameras and
[ __ ] and then the other was i guess like
she was like a second she was a medium
right i mean apparently yeah she's a
psychic medium and her name was lee
she's like she looked like a black metal
hippie chick she didn't well the actress
did it yeah i don't know what the real
girl because she wasn't they i don't she
wasn't on there was she the male the
other guy like the other paranormal
investigator he was on there talking
that's right i forgot i never found the
medium but i don't think the medium was
on there like the real one
yeah
the girl that played her in the movie in
the uh on the episode uh had black hair
parted down the middle and
wearing black and then later on she was
dressed kind of like a
like a heavy metal hippie or something i
wonder if she was on any other episode i
think she was like being like a gothic
witch to her like yeah or she who played
with a ouija board and yeah she got
everybody in trouble right she was
something like that probably i feel like
that's kind of what she got typecast as
yeah in in the haunting roster of
actors right so they all show up at this
point the family had been taking a bunch
of pictures around the house so they
showed the warrants the pictures now
most of them evidently were you know
just [ __ ] and not of anything but
one of them now this is interesting
because this is one of the few episodes
of a haunting i guess because it was the
first one and they hadn't really like
established the formula yet but they
actually did show
the actual picture yeah they didn't
usually they don't usually do that they
actually showed like actual picture and
actual artwork on this one but which
they don't usually that's usually a
paranormal witnesses bag but they did it
on this one and i thought the picture
was pretty good that's probably why they
showed it
yeah maybe that's why they just kind of
felt like well we're we'll show the
picture if it's
like
spooky looking but most of the pictures
are probably kind of like lame and it's
just like so they probably didn't show
just a picture of the inside of an
interior and where a door was there was
just kind of like a
it looked like uh some kind of chemical
problem
or something in the way that the film
developed it just looked like a gold
oblong shape there not very big
according to if to say the scale
probably about eight inches tall and
about
six inches wide kind of oval shape
yeah it did look odd it looked awful it
wasn't an orb like i couldn't tell what
i was i'm assuming that this picture was
probably taken in the spare room yeah i
guess i don't know if it was a spare
room or jennifer's room it looked like
somebody had taken a picture like of the
closet door
because this was the actual picture
right and it was like it wasn't a smudge
and it wasn't an orb no it was kind of
like i because i told when we were
watching it last night at whole time i
was like it looks like a shmoo
yeah it looks like a chemical some kind
of chemical problem in the way that the
film got developed like the
i don't know like some kind of acid fell
on the film or something something weird
it could have been
it could have been that uh but it was
odd that that was centered in the
photograph pretty much and it did look
weird
no it did kinda
they didn't see that when they took the
picture
uh but it could well that's implied they
didn't really say that out loud but well
if they said they saw it they would they
would have said that they just took a
picture of the door for some reason
maybe they had it well they were just
taking yeah they were just taking
pictures evidently they were just taking
pictures of the house just because they
felt weird and they felt a presence or
something maybe there was some kind of a
paranormal event happening and it
affected the way the film developed
so i'm not saying that that is a picture
of the daemon because that's that of
course that's what that's what [ __ ]
elizabeth warren's gonna say oh no
that's a demon lorraine the rain warmer
yeah she's gonna get man lorraine warren
i thought it was elizabeth but yeah
lorraine
she goes oh no that's a demon that's a
high level demon of course you know
because that's what lorraine even though
i said it looks like a shmoo it's a
shmoo demon
that's what i thought right it didn't
have a face on it it didn't look like i
kind of feel like if you
okay now if you took a picture of a
[ __ ] closet door in your house and
there was nothing there when you took
the picture and then you got the picture
developed for you for your kids you used
to have to take your film to get
developed instead of yet so i'm just i
had because i know we have some younger
listeners here who might be like what
are you talking about but um but yeah so
if you did that
and then you got the picture back
and the picture was like of a very
obvious like demon face like popping out
your closet then yeah i might be calling
i don't think i'd call the warrens but
yeah maybe i call an exorcist or
something this one seemed a little
ambiguous and honestly
it's a weird-looking photo i'm not
saying that but like even the mom bonnie
she was on there saying well
when i first saw the picture i didn't
really think that much of it i just
thought it was like something was wrong
with the film or it was like something
like that but then when they were
showing the pictures to the warrens
lorraine was like oh that's a really bad
demon you got right there i'm like how
can you tell it just looks like ishmael
yeah it's it looks like an irregularity
in the film but those were very rare
even back in those days but look at it
this way
when you're taking a picture you got
light coming into the camera it goes
into the lens and then it [ __ ]
flips around and projects itself on a
bunch of photosynthetic paper
maybe uh if there's some kind of weird
anomaly you know what i mean like a
paranormal
[ __ ] ghost
or a paranormal [ __ ] concept as
opposed to those non-parallel yeah right
maybe the light that's coming into the
camera maybe it's a little bit different
uh maybe it's been altered like like
like it's gone through a lens and then
it affects the way
the light
ended up being cast on the film on the
back of it so maybe some kind of quantum
anomaly may have been able to do but i
don't know i mean that seems like you
think you would be able to see it with
your eyes that seems like a big leap to
go from that to oh that's definitely
like a really bad like high level demon
yeah
lorraine but you know who knows maybe if
you [ __ ] maybe if you go astral or
something and you're actually projected
out of your body and so and
somebody takes a picture of where you're
looking at them from maybe the image
will be a little bit distorted for some
reason quantum physics or something
maybe somehow it affects the damn
light
but you would think that if you would
think that although maybe not
necessarily true but you would think
if it affected the photosynthetic paper
it would affect the back of your eye
you'd be able to see it
but
but see that's what happens but when i
had that weird out-of-body experience my
roommate when i was in the army did did
basically tell me he saw something up up
towards the ceiling he wouldn't tell me
what it was
it was probably just a feeling of being
watched probably
i don't really think you can see a
person
you know when they're
astral if that's
that's the word you want to use
well maybe you can i don't know
tammy says you wouldn't need to call the
warrens they would just show up
maybe that will yeah there maybe that's
what maybe there's something to it
because lorraine always said she was
psychic she's like i know that there's
going to be like [ __ ] they were
psyching they just like ring my doorbell
i'm like holy [ __ ] how did you guys well
they were psychic enough i took a
picture of a schmoo in front of my
closet it was
psychic enough to turn on the television
and read the newspaper and if [ __ ] a
case showed up on television or in the
newspaper they [ __ ] go running
towards it yeah to say yeah we did that
case
yeah we were on that case yeah that was
kind of their home that's where their
whole day that was kind of cool they
were on cases but they stole cases too
if if a big case was going on somewhere
they'd barge right in it's like we need
to get involved yeah and even though
even though they might just be there for
a few hours and then get kicked off but
then they go write a whole book about it
they write a whole book about it
yeah we were there go on go they go on
geraldo go on the talk show
yeah we handled that case yeah
one in this one it's like they did get
brought in but i kind of feel like you
know if if it was resolved i don't
really know if they had a lot to do with
it but you know we'll get into that so
yeah so the shmu picture
okay so
meanwhile like at this point the psychic
medium lady lee
uh you know the headbanger chick
she starts like doing like shaking like
she's possessed and some [ __ ] and then
she starts to do some automatic writing
she's like paper paper paper hold on one
thing what about the photograph it was
interesting
yeah yeah yeah it's like i said it
wasn't just like an orb like oh that's
clearly a bug but we took many pictures
with the old polaroid instamatic kind
where
we come out and develop we probably took
about 12 15 pictures maybe
during deer in uh mammoth mountain
and and we got pictures of stuff that
had moved things that it did making
shapes
making little happy faces and [ __ ] out
of rolled up towels but it there was
never any anomalies on the on on the
yeah i mean i've seen the photos they
don't look anything no no they just look
mundane
but they're crazy what the [ __ ] are we
taking pictures [ __ ] ray of folded up
time yeah that's what's creepy about
that why are we taking pictures of
[ __ ]
[ __ ] rocking chairs upside down with
[ __ ] towels [ __ ] folded over right
and [ __ ]
yeah it was because we we just were
[ __ ] we found it like that we were
amazed that's weird and you didn't know
my house and he did it in seconds you
know so we just took a picture of it
yeah
willie lee says really the warrens did
that yeah yeah that was kind of their
whole yeah bag that was 50 of their [ __ ]
yeah i mean i i mean
i guess once they got famous like people
did actually call them okay
but
another thing was that if there was a
case in a town like near there because
they lived in where connecticut like
somewhere in the northeast well then
that's why too well yeah but i'm just
saying like if there was a case that was
real popular yeah they would go then
they would go there and then they'd show
up and like offer their services as far
as they know they didn't ask for any
money no but you know which is good
because that would be really shitty they
would make money though
but they would later make money because
they would say oh i was on this case
that case and the other and sometimes
like i said they would write a book
about it or they would do like a lecture
tour about it they'd go on talk shows
and go on talking to talk about it and
talk about that they talk about other
stuff yeah that's kind of like that was
kind of their whole like business thing
yeah ed was a good businessman and he
was [ __ ] pushy and he was he would
bully his way through a situation
and if you if you defy him
or call [ __ ] he would just start
yelling
oh no oh no no he said you know he was
he was you know
yeah they kind of i kind of feel like he
was sort of like strong arms yeah
yeah he was he was kind of ghost
gangster he's ghost gangster that's a
good way of putting it that's what his
audit that's what his biography should
be
yeah ghost gangster yeah ed warren ghost
gangster well they said oh oh my god
yeah the conjuring movies don't show you
that do they no
no but and the thing about it is these
are [ __ ] cases that had dealt with
him
the books and the thing about it too is
that i mean the conjuring movies
uh i think the second one was based on
the enfield case and like i said in real
life
they did show up at the enfield case but
one they weren't invited i mean because
this it was in england
uh they heard about it so they flew over
there and everybody that was already
investigating the enfield case said they
showed up like one day and kind of like
tried to throw their weight around and
stuff but it's like they didn't really
do anything and then they left and then
they like made a whole movie about them
solving the [ __ ] like that that's not
what happened yeah it was
that one conjuring one that they did
that's what i just said yeah i think it
was the sack with the second one yeah i
think it was the second one it was all
based on them being there like a couple
of hours no no no excuse me the
conjuring
they weren't in
that one conjuring one that one actually
was uh a reinterpretation of this house
was haunted
i think i think the warrants do show up
in the movie don't they
well the whole conjuring universe is
based around the warrens they're every
single
so they're it's all based on them well
yeah that's kind of like the whole
conjuring okay and like i said the first
one
was the first one was the first one
uh [ __ ] no i can't remember wasn't the
smurls it was uh
crap i can't remember what it was but it
was kind of a case that they had
extensively worked in but i think the
second conjuring movie yeah was the
second or third one i can't remember the
second or third one was based on enfield
and i was like they absolutely did not
investigate enfield they showed up there
one day yeah because i read the book
from like that was written by the dude
that was there like the whole time he
was there for like what was he there
like 18 months or something he was there
for like a long there were two of them
there were two of them yeah
morris gross
parapsychology parapsychologist and
guideline player
and uh so he he was a journalist yeah
yeah yeah he was younger and he grew up
in brazil
brazil so they were both there like a
year and a half and they said yeah the
warrens like showed up from america like
we didn't nobody invited them they just
turned up yeah and they were there for
like a couple of hours yeah and we were
just like yeah we got this yeah and
and now it's like the conjuring movies
make it look like they solved the whole
[ __ ] like that's not like there's a book
called this house is haunted yeah which
i think it's been republished like since
the second conjuring movie so read that
because i don't even think they
mentioned the warrens in there i have to
read it again i have it somewhere i
think i just mentioned that other
investigators showed up they have to be
they had to be kicked off they said a
lot of them showed up they had to be
kicked off right yeah
yeah
but yeah that was just in the [ __ ]
yeah but that case was like i said
morris gross from the british uh you
know the psychical reason the psychical
research thing yeah and uh guy line
playfair who was like a journalist he
was interested in that kind of stuff
those were the two main guys and i think
there was another guy that was like
another journalist that came in and out
but they were there for like a year and
a half yeah not they weren't living
there but like for some time they would
like come every day and sometimes i
think they did stay there for like yeah
extended period on an interesting side
note play fair
um he got into the paranormal because
he um
saw
he was in when he was in brazil if i
remember correctly it was brazil i think
uh because i know he kind of grew up
there
he's investigating psychic surgeries
and said that they were phony except for
one he saw one dude that he can't
explain to this day he saw that dude
open another man's abdomen and look in
there he saw all the [ __ ]
guts and the intern the inside of that
guy's abdomen and he reached in there
and pulled out
something yeah because see usually they
just do this and like have a chicken
liver palm
[ __ ] like that yeah he said there's one
guy he couldn't explain he saw him open
up a
open up an abdomen and he could see
right into the right into that dude's
[ __ ] guts and then he reached in
there and pulled out something i forgot
what it was piece of cancer
pulled i think he cut some of it with a
[ __ ] knife a piece of cancer yeah but
pulled out some candy that sounds like
i'm gonna call it a [ __ ] a piece of
candy no i was gonna say that sounds
like a good that sounds like a good
title for like a story yeah a piece of
candy and he said he had a weird feeling
when it was going on when that went on
he was said he had the [ __ ] weird
feeling like he was seeing something
unnatural and then the guy sealed the
[ __ ] hole up somehow just rubbed it
like that in the [ __ ] hole sealed up
that he didn't see he'd never seen
anything like it
and that's what got him into the
paranormal and he never saw it he never
saw it again
weird said only that one dude did it
but i wasn't there yeah but so like i
said you know
we're just we've done a couple shows
about the warrens yeah so
there's a lot about them that uh the
conjuring movies are yeah yeah hyping or
yeah it's yeah it's not the way they
were not to say that they were on fake
cases i think they were on some real
cases
but i don't think it was demons
but a lot of the movies show them like a
lot more involved yeah a lot of
particular cases than they actually were
right right that's the thing
uh so yeah so at this point we got like
the psychic lee she starts to do like
the automatic writing like i said
and basically the automatic writing just
said get out get out get out
um you don't belong here stuff like that
like on this page
so the researchers then go and they set
up in jennifer's room now downstairs i
guess around the same time
bonnie the mom she seems to get sort of
kind of possessed briefly or at least
feels something like really cold like a
cold presence like passing through her
and then jennifer the daughter like she
feels the same thing a few seconds later
jennifer on the show said it felt like a
freezing cold entity thing like just
came out of the wall went through her
mom and then went through her she said
that's what it felt like that's kind of
where the pulse guys felt
so uh meanwhile the paranormal
researcher and they did re they did
interview the real guy on the show so
they had set up in jennifer's room and
he said that they recorded a bunch of
weird noises in there they didn't uh
play them on the show unfortunately
uh he said they recorded like knocking
on the walls the ceiling and the floor
and something i thought this was kind of
interesting something that sounded like
bird wings fluttering he said that's
what it sounded like uh so they recorded
that phantom noises
yeah so then he decided well let's try
and communicate with the entity or
whatever through knocking like once for
yes twice from now all that kind of
stuff so they claim that through this
method
they found out that there are
three human spirits in the house and
they're being kept there by of course a
demon because the warrens are there so
you know there has to be a demon
involved in the whole situation
sometime around here lee the psychic
gets possessed and starts doing the
automatic writing again
now on this one she writes three names
george robert and anna
and then she writes a full name
george robertson and then she writes a
number one eight and then a partial
eight
but before she can finish what she was
writing like a growly voice comes out of
her mouth saying stuff like why are you
questioning me blah blah then she shoves
they're in like the kitchen or the
dining room or whatever and then she
shoves the table kind of violently and
pins ed warren against the wall
you know so there was that whole thing
that was a very funny scene actually i
was kind of kind of amused well it's
like well the actor they had playing ed
warren didn't look anything like edward
actually the one they had playing
lorraine didn't look anything like
lorraine either but i just thought it
was kind of funny where they were just
gonna like speed it up kind of like whoa
oh my god i'm against the wall yeah
she's about the same age as lorraine but
lorraine was a [ __ ] bony little
bird-like old lady i'm skinny yeah
skinny little old lady yeah and the one
they got in the in the
show was more like a a little bit of a
dumpy like grandmotherly type
whereas yeah
lorraine always kind of like and she
always looks like she made 100 pounds
yeah and she always were there like
those really weird like victorian
clothes like with the high collars well
they were religious yeah and they were
kind of like baptists i know but i just
i thought that was always funny that she
was i guess that was kind of and after a
while i guess that was kind of like
their trademark or their brand or
whatever so it's like she yeah so she
can't like wear anything else you guys
want to do if you guys can look up what
their denomination was i know he just
called himself a religious demonologist
okay which that are there any other kind
of demonology yeah i mean that can mean
anything i'm an atheistic demon yes
what's he reading [ __ ] what's it
malefictorum or [ __ ] the devil's
hammer the malleus malefic yeah yeah
that's the witch's hand the witch's
hammer yeah i mean how does one become a
demonologist
i can think of is to [ __ ] read that
old [ __ ]
that's probably how yeah you can't get a
degree in it no thing i don't think
unless and from some like not accredited
anyway i'm sure i think they were some
kind of southern baptist yeah just just
read a bunch of like old demonology
books from like the from the middle ages
yeah and you're golden
although i don't think they were from up
north though so i don't know if they're
yeah i think they were from like
connecticut or something yeah weren't
they from connecticut yeah i don't think
there's too many southern baptist
churches up there and because you say
southern baptist
here in the south
that's a lot of leeway they're kind of
self-styled every church has its own
goddamn thing
who's the one that like danced with like
poisonous snakes and drink shrek oh
that's the [ __ ]
that's uh i don't even think they're
around anymore they're not the shakers
uh no no
no what are they called
it's just a snake cult they drink
they're drinking uh snake poison and
dancing with or that's what they say
they're doing anything they probably are
it's not snake poison it's arsenic
they're drinking red no i said stricken
straight knight yeah they drink straight
not rat and they let themselves get bit
by poisonous snakes although like i said
i don't know i don't think they let
themselves get bitten they handle them
because they're it's just based on a
verse that if basically like one
sentence based on one verse that if
you're really uh [ __ ] if if god's
really with you then you you can't be
harmed by poisons and snakes basically
is what it says and they just built a
whole religion
this is proof that i've i'm with god you
know it's like why don't you just like
keep reptiles like a normal person
instead of like having to build a whole
religion about it and then and then
they'd get bitten
and they'd die
and they go well he was a fake
other people
but see that's what i mean that's the
thing about religion that i never that
never like you know hangs right with me
it's just kind of like well whatever
happens oh it's fine yeah
it never makes them like question
they're like oh maybe we shouldn't be
like drinking poison or getting bitten
by poisonous snakes or something or
venomous snakes actually
no that's what i'm saying it's like but
see that's the thing that they can
always say though it's like even if
somebody gets bit by a venomous snake
and then they die they're like oh well
they obviously didn't have enough faith
i'm uh
me and jenny have come from very
different backgrounds so we have
different ways of looking at the [ __ ]
to me i i'm i'm a um i'm a i'm a
i would be i consider myself a christian
mythicist i don't believe any of that
happened it's mythology but that doesn't
mean mythology is lies
uh read joseph campbell mythology can
help a person
um [ __ ] do great things
um because faith
is powerful very powerful and sometimes
logic and reason [ __ ] fail you and
what got me through [ __ ] especially
military type stuff is just faith faith
in this [ __ ] supernatural faith and
destiny
faith in yourself faith in your friends
just all that kind of [ __ ] that would
[ __ ] really help you because a lot of
the [ __ ] a lot of
a lot of endurance
life is about endurance and endurance is
about [ __ ] mental power
of just not giving up
and that could save your life and if you
don't have that you could die
and every so religions are basically
doing that a good religion does that
gives you a survival skill
and
i can understand how some dudes would be
dancing with snakes and drinking poisons
because if they survive it then
they
their morale goes up okay they believe
stronger now they're [ __ ] have
they they kind of have an added survival
skill that you know i'm blessed [ __ ]
god's on my side i can do anything
it might help them help especially
definitely keep you from getting
depressed
but uh [ __ ] man there was [ __ ] we were
doing in the army the [ __ ] we should
have just walking ourselves to death in
the infantry you know [ __ ] freezing
cold [ __ ] hallucinating and [ __ ] what
got you through it was your faith in
yourself and your friends and your unit
and faith in your own strength and faith
in the supernatural and all that [ __ ]
it works
what star wars is about my strength
comes not from faith but from spite that
too oh yeah
oh yeah that's another thing is that
[ __ ]
many times you know what i mean [ __ ]
i trained with hatred in my heart that
actually you will actually get stronger
hatred can make you stronger yeah that's
that works that too
they teach people oh man hatred no hate
is a good thing it's a very good thing
if it's applied like i said i don't know
if it's so much i don't know if i'd call
it hatred i think spite is kind of like
just a better i just wanna i'm just
around because i'm stubborn yeah anger
if okay hatred is
propaganda in in warfare is always
designed to generate hatred in the
hearts of your of your forces and your
allies you do this by showing people
things that disgust them and anger them
and those two forces together cause
hatred and with hatred you could keep
your guys alive
and kill the enemy and then afterwards
suffer
much less [ __ ] psychological trauma
from it because
you don't care you don't even care if
you were right because you hated them
that's all
you know which
keep you from getting depressed and
later on you're like maybe we should
have done that
[ __ ] it
but it's too late those that's in the
past you know
camp guys said uh extreme northwest
georgia we had a guy die from a
rattlesnake bite about five or ten years
ago yeah yeah i mean it does happen like
rattlesnake bite usually if you can get
to a hospital you're fine but it's the
same thing as walking on coals and other
kinds of leaps of faith things that's
all it's the same thing
you can pick up a snake and not get
bitten
those snakes a lot of times have been
handled already so you can start dancing
with them but it just makes them feel
better i understand it
yeah you know like yeah it seems like a
stunt but okay yeah you know but so is
everything else that's like slam damp
and slam dancing in the mosh pit and
just doing other things make you feel
good too it's just like that just a
different way of looking at it this is
the philosophy behind it
and uh
that's what an exorcism is
yeah it's just like performance
performance art but if you believe it
it might work especially if the people
involved
you know what i mean the people you're
trying to help if they believe it it
might work
yeah the the power suggests is powerful
yeah i know yeah but yeah so anyway
let's get back to the
um so yeah
so we have this whole thing where she
pushed his head against the wall which
like i said i thought was very funny
so that night after that happens the
whole family sleeps together in the
living room
next day bonnie the mom and jennifer the
daughter they go to the town hall and
research the history of the house
and they find out that allegedly a man
named george robertson which is one of
the names that the psychic wrote down
did indeed own the house in 1888 which
was kind of almost like the date that
was written down by the psychic
they go to the local cemetery they said
and they immediately find his grave i
mean the mom said on the show she's like
oh we just walked to the cemetery
immediately like there was his grave
right there which was really really
weird now the guy died in 1927.
but they can't find out too much more
information about him because there was
a flood in town in 1955 apparently and
it destroyed a bunch of the records and
they said after this particular thing
happened they said for a few days
nothing happened and for a while they
kind of thought oh maybe it's fine
but then like one evening the kids are
wrapping christmas presents
and they're in one of the upstairs room
and then the doorknob to the room that
they're in like starts like violently
rattling right and nothing's happened
for a few days
so all three kids are like [ __ ]
terrified at this and they go tear an
ass down the stairs tell their mom uh
and the mom calls lorraine
so lorraine says okay well i'm gonna
call a priest and he'll come and like
bless the [ __ ]
um she's like i don't think it's gonna
get rid of the [ __ ] entirely it never
does usually it just makes it mad at
least according to these shows
um but
but they're like well maybe it'll lessen
it somewhat so it's not quite as bad so
the priest comes and does his little
hocus-pocus thing
and then like the family said okay well
the after that like the sort of
oppressive atmosphere or whatever seemed
to lift somewhat yeah they always say
that but then
two days later
bonnie starts feeling this overwhelming
compulsion to draw i will also note that
they showed her actual drawings on the
show which like i said they're pretty
great which were actually like quite
good i thought they were like a pencil
or charcoal or something like that
um so the first one they showed like she
draws this tree
and then like a sad looking woman and
like some other stuff and she described
it as being like there was a flood of
images and emotions that were just like
coming to her as though they were from
outside like she knew that they weren't
from her
um and she had to get them on paper like
she said sometimes it was just such a
compulsion that she would like stay up
all night like drawing
because she had to get all these images
out
and like i said she felt like she was
channeling that more than they were
coming from her so she says that she
became convinced that one of the spirits
anna who like i said that was another uh
name that the psychic wrote down that
anna is inside her head
and she said the impression that she got
was that this whoever this person was
had suffered some really great like
horrible loss although they didn't
really go more into it than that
so now one night
some undetermined time later
the family are all sleeping in the
living room again
and then suddenly a bunch of books start
flying off the bookshelves at them now
i'm not sure if it was anything like as
impressive as what they showed on the
show because on the show it's just kind
of like man shit's like flying out of
the bookshelves and there's like oh my
god like a barrage of [ __ ]
um so i'm not sure if it actually
happened like that nobody specifically
mentioned it that that's what had
happened
but whatever it was uh it must have been
something big or something significant
because bonnie calls lorraine and
lorraine says okay well i'm gonna set up
an exorcism
and she says oh it's gonna take a few
days for the priest to do all the
fasting and all the other pre-exorcism
[ __ ] that they have to do before they
get there so i think it's gonna i think
she said it's gonna be like three days
so the family is like okay well should
we like go stay at a motel or some [ __ ]
because this is getting bad we don't
really want to be here with like books
being thrown in our heads all the time
and lorraine says
well you can if you want but it's
probably
better to like stay in the house and
fight because even if you go to the
motel the [ __ ] will probably follow you
okay and so
you know oh yeah now
the rain
the rain is talking about demons but in
my experience poltergeist phenomena
actually does that because it's not fo
it's not centered in a place it's
centered around a person a person is
making it subconsciously
subconscious
is basically used in psychokinesis to
[ __ ] animate a fictional ghost or an
enemy it's usually
the idea is to hold the family together
against the common foe because the
family might be kind of breaking apart
it's just funny how
the warrens would take things that were
known about in 1960s parapsychology but
instead of saying it's rspk there's no
it's demons
they did seem to genuinely believe that
everything was demons i will say because
well lorraine did i don't know right i
don't know if ed really believes because
ed lorraine did not believe that the
bible supports the ideas of [ __ ]
paranormal abilities but the new
testament says that
constantly people using the power of god
people channeling the power of god the
angel of god descending upon somebody
saying this is my son and then then he
can do miracles it's all paranormal [ __ ]
and then they're casting out demons
they're becoming exorcists
christianity was an exorcism cult back
in first second century
kind of doing what the warrens were
doing basically
yeah yeah they're they're originalists
this morning right yeah yeah
so yeah so she says no you probably just
stay there save your money like don't go
to the ramada or whatever because the
demons just gonna follow you so they
decide to stay in the house so while
they're in the house like bonnie does
another drawing and they showed this one
as well and this one was like it was
kind of like it looks sort of like a
crooked pyramid type situation and then
it had like a big white light like
glowing at the top of the pyramid and
then on one side of the pyramid there
were kind of like beams of blue too like
heavenly light or whatever and then on
the other side there was like a really
bad storm with lightning and all this
other kind of crap there was also three
kind of like ghosty figures like they
were kind of like floating up towards
the pyramid and then there was like a
like a heart that was like broken in
half or something like that
so it was that i don't know what that
meant they didn't really go into it
um
so bonnie's mom who noped the [ __ ] out
back on thanksgiving did and with we
don't know if she got any turkey or not
because for some reason that was a
really important question for me
but she decides she doesn't like the
house but she's like well it's christmas
so i'm going to come back so bonnie's
mom comes back for christmas
but she's only in the house for a very
short time and then she apparently
develops a very like an unexplained very
very high temperature of 104
degrees
so bonnie takes her to the hospital
and the doctors find out that the
grandma
uh also has a really weirdly like
irregular heartbeat like i don't know if
they had any kind of medical diagnosis
they didn't say on the show
so they decide that they're gonna keep
her overnight for observation because
they don't know what's the matter with
her
so apparently bonnie's mom grandma was
like really religious um and said
prayers every night so bonnie and
jennifer are at the hospital visiting
her and they said that grandma is like
doing her nightly prayers
but she can only she couldn't say them
right like she could only say them
backwards so i was like ooh
demonic but yeah so she can only say i'm
backwards and so but it gets a little
freaked out about the situation
meanwhile
at around the same time as all of that
is going on
the older daughter the one that we don't
know what her name is
uh she's out in the car running errands
like christmas errands and she gets in a
wreck
now she isn't hurt badly but the car is
apparently totaled like i said it sounds
like a coincidence
but you know i i can see how they
probably like uh linked all of that
together
so uh back at the hospital a priest
comes to the hospital and says prayers
over bonnie's mom
she said that while he was initially
while he was saying the prayers she felt
like she was being punched in the
stomach but then like he gave her like a
comedian wafer and then like it all went
away so i guess there's that and then i
don't think that they'd talk about her
anymore
three days later
it's exorcism time
exorcism time
so they bring in lee the psychic who
apparently uh they tie her to the chair
right um with duct tape and [ __ ] uh
because apparently she's gonna be the
conduit for the demon
because that's how this works
so
this i don't know i kind of feel like
this with the end of this one was a
little anti-climactic because they did
like tie the psychic to the chair and
then she does like kind of your standard
possession [ __ ] like yeah
you know what i mean like screaming and
yelling and just stop praying and blah
blah blah and like doing all that kind
of stuff um
but she gives everybody apparently she
gives everybody like this big wicket
grin and then like breaks the chair
she's tied to which is very funny
because we were talking about this
because
they were like well no human could have
broken a chair i'm like seriously it was
probably just like a shitty like regular
ass dining room chair i said if you were
tied to a chair and you were determined
enough you could probably break those
that's the only way especially the old
wooden 80s to 70s that's what i'm saying
you said a little peg sticking at the
bottom you snap that [ __ ] peg yeah
you could probably pull that off if you
tried hard enough legs were strong yeah
if you were just kind of like
you know what i mean and like i said i
wasn't there i just probably what she
did is just she her legs were tied to
the tie to the to the to her if her legs
were tied to the legs of the chair she
probably just leaned forward until she
was on her feet and then stood up and
that was just yeah and it would just
like pull it yeah because like i said
there's the chairs weren't they weren't
made of like titanium or anything like
that it's just like usually wood
so so yeah so after that there's kind of
like some word yelling and screaming and
then the exorcism actually just seemed
to work and it was just kind of like oh
okay the end um
and
there was that they didn't even do like
i i was waiting for lorraine to bring up
the odor of sanctity thing but she never
got in this episode i kept saying like
do we small roses are we smelling roses
come on lorraine belle roses
these things
that's like
but i was waiting for it i was waiting
for it but she doesn't say it
so the exorcism seemed to work like i
said which that's crazy because normally
they're just kind of like yeah we didn't
exorcism but then like it was fine for a
while and then like [ __ ] got really bad
again and we had to like get the [ __ ]
out
that's not what happened everything was
fine now everything was apparently
hunky-dory after that for several years
they said
but then
uh
you know a few years later a developer
starts kind of like digging into the lot
across the street from their house
and uh apparently found one of those
good old native american burial grounds
yeah you can't keep them out of the
place i know but they caused so many
hauntings
yeah just everywhere um and they said
that after that happened like after that
was unearthed oh sex bot get rid of the
sex spot please uh oh yeah somebody get
rid of the sex spot
does anybody actually really ever check
out like
click on those
i don't i don't it just seems like a
waste of the channel okay it seems like
a wave
there you go
oh boy love chat xyz yeah
i can't wait
to go to the end like the best adult
dating site
i don't know maybe somebody will click
on it i guess no i took some of it off
okay yeah like i can't do it from here
so we don't i don't know if we have any
other like i don't see any little
wrenches or anything like that yeah sex
but ever come out of nowhere sex spots
but yeah so they said that after that
happened that like some diminished
paranormal activity started happening at
the house again but it wasn't really all
that bad so they just decided that they
could live with it and like i said this
the show aired in 2005 and they lived in
the house and they moved into the house
in 1998 i'm not entirely sure like how
long they lived there
the only other source that i found now
this is kind of interesting
not a hell of a lot of outside info on
this one
the only thing that i really found
there was an article
in the valley independent sentinel
for this area like of connecticut and it
was dated july 24th 2012.
and it talked about this case a bit now
mostly it talked about it in the context
of
in 2012
six people aged 18 to 22
got arrested on this property for
trespassing
on friday the 13th of 2012 after they
went there to do some ghost hunting
they said it was five men and one woman
and they weren't from seymour like the
town were the houses
they said that they got the idea
from
not a haunting show because that had
been like a few years in the past at
this point but they said there was a
friday the 13th radio broadcast of
something called the chas and aj show on
a local radio station i guess called
wplr and the djs said what the address
of the real house was what
um so they decided they were going to go
there and check it out that's a lot now
as well yeah i mean i don't know if that
how that happened but yeah so as usual
uh the house they used on the show was
not the actual house that the article
did mention the house was on buckingham
road i didn't say what the number was
but um but you know buckingham road
seymour i don't know how long that you
know i'm not from there uh seymour
connecticut but that's what they said
the house was but they didn't say what
the number was but apparently this radio
show said what the address was so they
went there look people don't go down
there [ __ ] with those uh that house
all right it's not that house
uh if the case is correct if it happened
the way
um the haunting told it
it's probably poltergeist which means
it's not the house it was it was the
girl
and she just and you know she outgrew it
and it stopped
that's so it's not location based it's
people-based
so like according to the article
according to this article from 2012
nobody in town particularly remembered
this house being haunted until a
haunting talked about it in 2005. right
now they did talk to one guy whose name
was dan rivera and he lived in seymour
and he founded the connecticut old
school paranormal like group
he didn't necessarily deny that the
house was haunted but he said basically
just what you said he said if it was
back then then it was dealt with back
then and there probably isn't anything
going on there right now yeah um so you
know please don't go there
now in 2012 when this article was
written i don't know when the beckwith
family moved out but in 2012 when the
article was written the house had been
vacant for many years
uh and the article went on to say that
it was owned by a guy named uh taylor
khan who lives overseas i don't know if
this is still relevant because like i
said this was 10 years ago
um
that says it had been in foreclosure
and khan acquired its site unseen in
2009 as part of a deal to buy two other
foreclosed properties
uh in 2012 he was trying to sell the
property
but said it needs uh 20 to 40 000 worth
of work to fix it up right um they
apparently asked the guy they said well
is the house haunted
um or they didn't ask the guy that owned
it but they asked like the lawyer that
was representing him like the real
estate lawyer
and the guy says
if you want to buy a haunted house it's
a haunted house and if you don't want to
buy a haunted house then it's not on it
i was like that's a good answer
um now other residents who live nearby
said they don't remember anything bad
ever happening at the house and they
don't remember any rumors about it being
haunted prior to that episode airing in
2005 so
take it that way you will we're not
saying like the family was lying or
anything like that but
we are saying that the house doesn't
have any history behind it it's not like
oh that's the local haunted house and
this family bought it like there wasn't
really anything about that yeah so it's
i believe it's poltergeist and
poltergeist is not location-based it's
people-based just reiterating it yeah
the uh the the issues with the people
were resolved and the phenomenon [ __ ]
subsided
but you go there and you could go to
that house now and there'd be nothing
there
yeah and that's basically what that
other person was saying too it's just
and i don't know if he was just saying
that to like discourage people from
going there like those people that got
arrested for trespassing in 2012 but
you know i'm just saying there hadn't
been like i said it didn't have a
history of
being haunted because i did look it up
and it's crazy because i was looking it
up and i looked up their
last name which was beckwith because
they used their last their real last
name on the show
and i came up with this one site and it
had like pictures of a real house and i
was like oh this must be the real house
but then i realized that there's another
beckwith haunted house but it's in
michigan so it's not the same house you
know what i mean so and i didn't even
realize that until i started looking at
the pictures and reading it i was like
oh wait this is michigan like this other
one's connecticut so it's totally
different
um hugo said have you seen or reviewed
the vast of night yes we did yes we did
um
that was a while back but yeah i really
really did like that movie you liked
that movie too yeah i don't remember
which one that was that was the one
about like it was set in the 1950s and
then like the uh they kept hearing the
like the alien signals like coming over
the radio and [ __ ] like that yeah that
was a really good movie was it was that
like i feel like that was like an amazon
original or something like that it was
interesting but yeah that was a good
movie i liked that a lot but we did a
review of it i don't remember how long
ago was it was a while back
um
captain crazy said i'll stay away from
that house yeah so like i said i know
what street it's on but i don't know
what's right but like i said there's
probably nothing going on there anyway
and i don't know if anybody because like
i said that article said that it was you
know that nobody lived there but that
was back in 2012. so i don't know if
somebody's bought it and fixed it up or
if they torn it down or i couldn't
really find anything about it so
that's so there you go
all right so
are you are you
done yeah man we went on for an hour and
a half about that [ __ ]
all right so
i guess that'll do it for today we'll
have to go and uh find a movie to watch
to talk about tomorrow
so hopefully you guys will join us again
tomorrow evening where we talk about a
movie we don't know which one is going
to be yet but it'll be a surprise to you
guys and to us so thanks for hanging out
with us this evening and we'll see you
guys again tomorrow
bye